les secrets de la conception des
enjoliveurs des roues des véhicules
renault c'est ce qu'ont pu découvrir ces
quinze étudiants de l'estaca de montigny
le bretonneux ces futurs ingénieurs dans
l'automobile ont reçu des explications
d'anthony zamani farhi pilote composants
enjoliveurs l'objectif soutien peut leur
montrer qu est-ce que l'ingénierie
automobile comment nous on apercevait
dans notre domaine on est dans un très
grand groupe et donc c'est très
important d'être organisée et le fait
d'être organisé ne me permet d'être plus
efficaces et j'essaie des points que
vous les montrer pour eux parce que
c'est la particularité d'être rigoureux
dans l'entreprise c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel je trouve que ça nous permet
d'avoir une vision sur
qu'est ce que le métier d'ingénieur
parce que quand on à l'école ça c'est
abstrait au final ça nous a permis de
mieux comprendre l'environnement
travaille chez renault pour les
ingénieurs et aussi de voir du coup tous
leurs processus de travail est vraiment
déjà dix mille personnes qui travaillent
sur le site plus cent vingt mille
personnes autour du monde qui vont bat
pas on en grande partie si tous
travailler sur un même produit ce moment
des changes s'inscrit dans le cadre de
la visite du technocentre par ces
étudiants de l'école d'ingénieurs de
montigny le bretonneux un événement
organisé durant la semaine de
l'industrie un rendez vous
incontournable pour l'estac a dans ses
relations avec les entreprises ça permet
pour eux de se projeter de pouvoir poser
des questions à un intervenant qui
finalement est un peu leur projection du
futur
ça leur permet aussi de comprendre les
rouages de l'ingénierie de leur futur
métier découverte des futurs véhicules
du groupe renault des dernières
innovations technologiques dans le
secteur automobile cette visite du
technocentre a pu confirmer la vocation
de ces quinze étudiants de l'estaca